can I ask you a question what do you
think what do you think
men want on a marriage if you give me
three things what the guy what the man
wanted America give me three things just
three
wow
that's good question because most of the
time they get married because the women
are the one all the time asking and
being like right but if I if a guy is
okay if a guy's thinking what his wife
would do for him what's one thing she
would do like the first thing that comes
to your head
in a marriage for a man yeah
what did he not get until he was married
in the old days
family children
okay okay
that's okay okay that's fine that's one
he does get children out of a marriage
what else